[Rires]
[Musique]
il était dans ma classe il était dans Ah
non
continue tu es chez toi j'ai passé une
aventure magnifique je me je sais pas je
sais pas quoi dire juste merci à toute
l'équipe d'Anthony parce que tout le
long ils m'ont reboosté il y a eu des
moments de super difficiles avec la
diffusion ils m'ont appelé jusqu'à 23h
où je pleurais quand une madeleine merci
évidemment à tous les ICOS merci pour
tous c'était fou bravo à toi je sais que
tu as bossé comme un fou je vous garde
pour la fin allô allô est-ce qu'il y a
quelqu'un moi j'ai 7073 euros à vous
offrir
bon alors
ça fonctionne pas a priori il faut
rester près de son téléphone je vous le
dis et je vous le redis mais vous
imaginez un petit peu
peut-être qu'on vous a appelé vous
n'avez pas décroché donc on est en train
d'appeler un autre numéro
mais c'est pas possible en France
est totalement quelle habitude de les
recevoir leur poser cette fameuse
question ils savent exactement combien
ils gagnent et souvent après l'émission
Benjamin il me disent en coulisse
franchement Jordan je peux pas te dire
la somme c'est tellement indécent je
vais me faire défoncer sur les réseaux
sociaux
ça veut dire qu'en France on ne peut pas
dire honnêtement et clairement combien
on gagne parce que effectivement le
problème c'est que c'est mal vu d'avoir
de l'argent
[Applaudissements]
366000 euros 59 victoires
[Musique]
bonjour bon retour Charlotte quand on a
gagné autant de d'entrer
et voilà
d'entrer après je pense à Magic Chang
par exemple qui avait gagné la palme
d'orpectation je vais y arriver je n'ai
pas bu hein de la meilleure actrice
elle a arrêté après parce qu'elle s'est
dit qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce que je
découvre
sur TF1 c'était énorme vous aviez
combien 100000 certains mois pas tous
les mois mais il y avait des 1000 euros
un record battu à Dubaï ou les plaques
d'immatriculation s'achètent à coup de
millions
réservé aux ultras ultra riches qui ne
cesseront jamais de me fasciner comme
lorsque l'un d'eux samedi dernier a
dépensé 55 millions de dirham ce qui est
quasiment 14 millions d'euros pour
détenir ceci que vous allez voir c'est
la photo de la semaine une plaque
d'immatriculation avec le chiffre 7 et
seulement le chiffre 7 qui est sacré
dans la religion musulmane
30000 euros hors taxes
c'est entre 15 et ça dépend par rapport
à ce qui rapportait je trouve que c'est
important
hyper tôt
sachez que dans les Émirats arabes unis
désormais avoir une Rolls-Royce ne
suffit plus il faut aussi l'immatriculer
avec le moins de chiffres possible c'est
la BBC qui rapportait ce bouleverse en
bouleverse en témoignage d'un certain
Abou Saba millionnaire qui s'était vu
refuser l'entrée d'un grand hôtel dubaïa
car ça Rolls Royce fantôme à 800000
dollars avait trop de chiffres sur sa
plaque d'immatriculation vulgaire là
honte on se demande parfois comment
certains automobilistes arrivent à se
retrouver dans des endroits pareilles
mais c'est quand on tente de les
remorquer qu'on comprend comment ils en
sont arrivés là quand la pente est
glissante en général ça finit mal
[Musique]
bon bah là au moins on est sur qu'elle
n'ira pas plus bas la vidéo de ce
week-end pascal qui a le plus tourné sur
les réseaux elle vient d'une église une
église italienne
un petit temps calme au son des
carillons et des oiseaux quand soudain
un invité surprise
[Musique]
une immense frayeur pour cette américain
devoponheimer alors le camion poubelle
tout automatisé attention et une vieille
dame ah oui
[Rires]
Jean-Paul Sartre disait
la patrie l'honneur la liberté il n'y a
rien l'univers tourne autour d'une paire
de fesses on a donc décidé aujourd'hui
de louer de célébrer cette partie du
corps objet de désir mais également de
complexe
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
c'est un chameau coquin si certains
décident de passer des heures à la salle
de sport à enchaîner les squats pour
faire gonfler leurs fessiers d'autres
viennent de trouver une méthode beaucoup
plus rapide détourner l'usage du
periacine un médicament anti-allergique
disponible en vente libre avant de 10
euros il fait aussi prendre du poids et
donc des fesses ça
marche ça fait grossir tout de suite
j'ai le plaisir et l'honneur de déclarer
le troisième championnat du monde de
Docteur Maboul ouvert
moi une coloscopie c'est mon pied ici ah
bon vous en fait souvent
mais Daniel ça se fait sous anesthésie
générale mais alors vous dormez mais
j'adore être endormi parce que je suis
insomniaque vient de me faire endormir
non ce qui est bien quand on vous fait
une coloscopie c'est que ça vous vide la
tête
[Musique]
c'est parti
c'est la marque des vrais champions de
ne pas trembler
[Musique]
une fraction
c'est Nabilla qui a dû récemment subir
une opération de chirurgie esthétique
parce qu'en fait elle explique que elle
dormait toujours du même côté et du coup
elle est ce qu'on appelle une crevaison
de Sein
c'est du faux de dormir
un matin il avait une crevaison comme
une bagnole
c'est ce qu'elle dit
[Applaudissements]
non c'est trop pour moi franchement
j'étais sûr de gagner là j'ai même pas
pour la finale faites une ovation pour
Lucile la nouvelle champion du monde
merci beaucoup général
Jean-Louis Georgelin j'espérais un oui
madame et un merci Madame pour conclure
cette émission
j'ai pas bien entendu merci Madame
[Rires]